bientôt les québécois vont être appelés
à voter
alors que les partis politiques se
retrouveront sous les feux de la rampe
ben coulisses le directeur général des
élections se préparent pour tout une
opération contient ces affiches dans une
souris du var qu'il faut expliquer aux
gens de quoi ils auront besoin pour
pouvoir exercer leur voix ça va de
l'imprimante du portable il y a les
directives qui sont dans sa yo les
crayons ça va vous début à la fin que le
crayon et particuliers à la mine
suffisamment grâce c'est presque un
million de jeunes ou de votre saut c'est
un objectif ronde tenté d'informer les
gens de les amener à voter
[Musique]
alliant concernant la réponse les gens
ont peur était légèrement à côté me
donne mon goût de voter puis je vais y
aller une souris derrière son dos il y à
sa question pour lui
penses-tu pourquoi penses-tu qu'il est
important de voter et ils ont les
réponses que je ne vous mens pas enlever
les fêtes surprise il répond à cette
question là et olemps même jour du vol
on veut rendre quelques jours après on
va rendre public le résultat de petites
scènes
[Musique]
à l'élection la kia d'afrique ce c'est
la permission de pouvoir se préparer à
la vente pour organiser cette immense
base logistique
[Musique]
cette vaste opération coûte une petite
fortune 93 millions de dollars dont 48
millions sont destinés à la rémunération
des employés et 9 millions au
remboursement des dépenses électorales
des partis politiques
[Musique]